well let's talk about the Fitness with
skies Laura boondock who joins me now
and and Laura figures going up by
another 494 lives the government is
obviously concerned about the prospect
of there being another peak yeah that's
right and it's interesting hearing from
Professor diamond there because he is
talking about the fact we've got lots of
different epidemics within the UK so
that's not just epidemics occurring in
hospitals but it's important to look at
those in care homes and in the community
as well and what the figures from the
ons is showing us is that in all of
those categories the figures are coming
down but they're coming down more slowly
particularly when it comes to care homes
and of course you need to be able to get
on top of this death rate to make sure
it continues to fall because if it
doesn't then we'll start to see a rise a
number of deaths and that will create
the second peak and that's what everyone
is worried about professor diamond is
also worried about the death rates when
it comes not just to covert related
deaths but the indirect death so the
deaths where people aren't looking
aren't accessing the health care they
maybe need to this is known as the
excess mortality for all causes so the
number of deaths them to higher than
normal that we they expect and so there
is a worry that would be an increase in
deaths surrounding excess mortality
generally it can also speak about a
spike in in mortality rates further down
the line so if people aren't being
referred for cancer services for example
or indeed if the recession isn't
v-shaped if it's an l-shape recession so
it drops down and then stabilizes at a
low level there is a fear this will push
more people into poverty and we know
poverty is strongly linked to mortality
as well so lots of concerns here and all
linked in to whether or not we can and
whether or not we should start to ease
more of the lockdown
lots of people are concerned about this
including Sir David King who's the
former chief scientific adviser for the
UK here's what he was saying a little
earlier
how do you think we can hear from him at
the moment but certainly he is concerned
that lifting of lockdown measures does
indeed mean that if you do it too early
then we will increase the chances of the
second peak another thing in terms of
being able to keep on top of the virus
at the moment is to be able to rapidly
detect any outbreaks where they recur
when they recur at a regional level and
we need to be able to keep a cross where
these are happening
professor diamond thinks it's very
important that we start to digitalize
death certificates so that they can be
registered and within 24 hours because
that will give us a more accurate a much
faster picture in terms of where we're
seeing the virus spreading okay Laura
thanks very much for that